the southern lights suggest we suggested
starting my pretty met number two in
front of the X we could put it on the
two in other places as well where else
would I put it whoa okay so we will get
2 sine squared X soon but for now I want
to look at somewhat simpler
modifications of the graphs which are
basically sort of moving in now but
still somewhat recognizable as the sine
x coordinate cos x curve when we get 2
sine squared which is actually more of
an extension contemn you'll see that
looks quite different okay so stay
without any powers or what have you
another place that I could put the 2 is
not even with the X but outside not the
front so I could consider this okay no
come back to your calculator right if
you know I just monkey about with values
and try to see what's happening right if
I put in rather the sine 2x 2 sine and
then try some angles try surveillance
right the first thing I do is I'm gonna
just humor me I'm gonna go to sine 0
now before you hit equals what do you
expect to happen you should expect 0
because you've got this guy beside 0 is
0 if you double 0 you still have 0 right
so that's fine now when you hit equals
it does confirm for you let's try
another thing let's try say 2 sine 90
okay now when you hit equals it supplies
you another isn't what you expected and
do you see why it has to be that
particular value right
what's sine 90 normal so not one it's
one right there it is but you said don't
give me sad night to give me two sine 90
so instead of being here one he goes
higher up to 2 because that's John Cena
when I go back to sign 280° to sign of
hundred eighty degrees is still two
times zero so it's to zero right so all
of those intercepts are going to be the
same but I go twice as high and I could
also good twice as low because once I
get to here and what name was that
bubbling be able to get me to this
turning point is 200 study if you go to
sign 270 it's gonna go two times
negative one which is negative two
okay so the graph is get a little much
the same in fact I'm going to draw is
the same but to distinguish between what
I've been doing over here and what we've
been doing over there the difference is
of vertical scales so I did mention the
pictures with some obvious but here the
up and down doesn't change its these
values in here that change right so now
I've got no frequent in two cents so my
scale a little bit okay whereas over
here it's not changing horizontally it's
actually changing vertically do you see
that so this is two and this is negative
two okay everything else is what it was
on the original curve okay so what do we
call this changing this way up and down
we called amplitude okay yeah image is
actually much too long I think the
frequency in period frequency appear to
be more confusing I'm gonna say
something now though that has the
potential to confuse you in the short
term but I hope long term Basin three if
I said you see them okay teacher notes
in the first thing we change frequency
in period which is a horizontal thing do
you agree so I want you to imagine the
sine curve a bit like it accordion right
so you can like stretch it out or you
can squeeze it in and that makes sense
cuz look away the numbers are that we're
changing over here look away the two is
and where the half is what is it
attached to it's attached to the X right
and X is about horizontal sort of
squeezing and squashing just that make
sense now what you have a look at it
here we're changing amplitude now that's
not about horizontal changes is it
horizontally this thing looks identical
to the original graph it's not a
horizontal or cornea it's a vertical
equator now that's not obvious in the
way that I've written it right now so
I'm going to change it a little bit I'm
gonna write it I'm gonna suggest you
write on the side as well as 1/2 Y now
you always never see it like this where
you tend to write things which Y is the
subject when you're graphing things but
I wonder if this helps you understand
what is going on and how this is similar
to what's happening over here that
number there the hub or the two
depending on which way you look at it
what it's really modifying is the Y
values which is an up/down quantity okay
it really actually doesn't belong over
here this is what it's changing this is
about vertical adjustment okay so if I
were to say okay how much has this been
squashed or squeezed up and down right I
am going to have within from one to
negative one I only get half of it
that's what this means right
to go to the full way I can't just say
between 1 and negative 1
I've gotta go 3 to negative 2 okay so I
like to write things like this because
it clarifies for me what's actually
being changed the answer is why is it
being changed it's not as obvious you